you're watching The Bachelor the season  do you watch the show of course I  totally watch it i watch it and i like  the rest of us you know everybody's like  I never watched it before my season and  I've hardly even watched my own and now  I'm like I'm a cult follower I watch it  every Monday I'm obsessed The Bachelor  alum shared a few tips with et at the  ESPN the party event for future  contestants hoping to find love on the  reality show what's your advice to the  girls that are going on the show gosh  it's funny to put myself like back as a  contestant like one of 25 women first of  all for any girl that's going on the  show next time comfortable shoes 100%  but you know what turn have fun I mean  it's very very easy to get lost in it  and get very emotional obviously and  then two months later you look back and  you're like wow that was actually fun  stressed out about in the moment not so  easy yeah my advice don't stress just  enjoy life's good